one of the most important things to
consider when flying an aircraft is the
weight and balance every aircraft has
limitations if the airplane's too heavy
it'll have trouble getting off the
ground on a takeoff it'll have trouble
stopping when it goes to land and the
wings might not be able to create enough
lift in order to be able to fly now
we'll be discussing weight and how it
affects performance in a future episode
but in addition to that the aircraft
must be balanced properly so you can
actually control it and if it's not
there are a few problems you could run
into before we discuss those I want to
explain what it means to have a balanced
airplane when discussing this topic most
instructors use the illustration of a
seesaw or a teeter-totter or whatever
you call it
what happens when there's more weight on
one side of the Seesaw the Seesaw is no
longer balanced but as you know there
can also be the same exact amount of
weight on both sides and if the weight
gets closer to the fulcrum on one of
those sides it will still be out of
balance airplanes work the same way but
instead of a fulcrum like the one we see
on a seesaw all the weight of an
airplane balances on what we call the
center of lift when the wing of an
airplane creates lift all the lifting
forces that the wing produces don't all
go in exactly the same direction but if
you were to average out those forces you
could see that most of the lift is
generally concentrated in One Direction
and this is what we call the airplane
Center of lift and you might also hear
some instructors refer to this as the
center of pressure but no matter what
you call it this is basically the
fulcrum on an airplane and the weight of
an aircraft is kind of like a cradle
that is suspended from this point now I
do want to point out that the center of
lift does move when you change your
airplane's angle of attack as a a
general rule if you increase the angle
of attack on an airplane the center of
lift moves forward and this is important
to remember because your airplane may
have been balanced enough to control it
at a low angle of attack but if you're a
little too tail heavy you can see that
the airplane might become impossible to
control if you increase the angle of
attack too much in this situation we'll
go into a little bit more detail on this
in just a minute
next we have the center of gravity and
the easiest way to explain this is to
look back at our seesaw the center of
gravity is basically the point on our
seesaw where we need to put our fulcrum
if we want the weight on our seesaw to
be balanced it's basically the average
place on something where the weight is
concentrated
but oddly enough we don't put the center
of gravity right on our fulcrum or
Center of lift on an airplane and here's
why
as you know the engine and the nose of
your airplane is super heavy and it
would be almost impossible to balance
that out with something else in the tail
without adding too much weight to the
airplane
instead What airplane manufacturers do
is they essentially put an upside down
Wing back here at the back of the
airplane
and what that does is it gives us a
downward Force to balance out our heavy
engine without adding a bunch of extra
weight and now that you know that you
can kind of start seeing what needs to
happen in order for our airplane to
balance out in flight
first the center of gravity needs to be
in front of the center of lift this
allows the elevator or stabilator to do
its job and to create a downward force
that will balance out our Center of lift
with our center of gravity but if you
remember from our lesson on how an
airplane creates a lift this means that
in order for our airplane to be balanced
we need to have some air moving over the
tail in order to balance out the
aircraft this is why the nose of the
airplane feel so heavy when you're first
trying to take off and you haven't built
up enough air speed then once you build
up enough air speed the airplane wants
to pitch up and climb out on its own
because of all that excessive tail
downforce created by the relative wind
and once you start practicing those soft
field takeoffs you're going to really
struggle keeping the airplane from
climbing out of ground effect because of
that and that's the whole point of
elevator trim it basically allows you to
position your elevator or stabilator so
it will give you a certain amount of
tail down force and this allows you to
balance out the airplane in flight
that's why you need to re-trim the
aircraft anytime you change your air
speed now let's talk about what would
happen if you had your center of gravity
too far forward and this would mean that
you have too much weight in the nose of
the aircraft
well the first thing you'll notice is
the obvious you're going to have a hard
time raising the nose of the airplane
you may not have enough tail downforce
to overcome the weight you have in the
nose then if you ever do get the
airplane up in the air it's going to
take a lot more extra downforce on the
tail to keep the nose up so you can fly
straight and level in extreme nose heavy
situations you could even potentially
have full nose up trim and still need to
pull back on the Yoke to maintain level
flight I don't even want to think about
a situation where I would need to climb
because there's something in front of me
and I can't overcome the weight of the
nose because I put too much weight up
there in the front
another problem with this is that when
you do this you're pushing the tail down
which also increases your angle of
attack and this does a couple things
first you can't fly quite as fast
because you're at a high angle of attack
and there's more drag on the airplane
but you also increase your airplane's
stall speed when you do this because
you're closer to your critical angle of
attack so this can be a problem as well
but what happens when you have too much
weight in the back of the airplane or
the center of gravity is too far aft
well think about what the Tail's doing
that's the key here remember the tail is
balancing out the weight of our airplane
so we can control it with that in mind
if your tail is heavy you don't need as
much tail down Force to keep the nose up
and there's even less drag on the
airplane now because we're flying at a
lower angle of attack and that means we
can fly faster air speeds at first
glance this might seem ideal but
remember what I mentioned earlier the
tail is balancing out our aircraft on
the center of lift if the tail is too
heavy and the center of gravity is
farther back the airplane becomes less
stable this gets even worse at slower
air speeds because the center of gravity
moves back even more as you increase the
angle of attack to maintain altitude
in addition to that the center of lift
also moves forward as we mentioned
earlier and it doesn't take much for the
airplane to get out of balance and when
that happens it becomes completely
uncontrollable in tail heavy situations
if you were to get yourself into a stall
or a spin you're pretty much toast I
hope you enjoyed your life at least you
got to fly a few times before you died
anyways you're likely most not going to
be able to recover the aircraft and
that's the whole reason why we calculate
the weight and balance of our airplane
for each aircraft the manufacturer has
already done all the hard math for you
they give you a limitation for how nose
heavy the airplane can be and they also
give you a limit for how tail heavy the
airplane can be and as long as you stay
within those boundaries they're pretty
much guaranteeing that you're going to
be able to control the airplane
in just a minute I'm going to explain
how to know whether or not you're in
those limits but first I want to point
out that these limits can also depend on
what you're using the airplane for
notice on this chart we have two
categories normal and utility now don't
worry I'm going to explain how to use
this spaghetti chart in just a minute
and it's really simple but for now I
just want you to see that the airplane
manufacturers have decided that if
you're going to be doing certain things
like spins or other types of approved
aerobatics the Ford and app limits you
have to work with are smaller in this
utility category which allows you to do
a few more things with the airplane in
addition to the smaller CG limits you
also have to be a lighter weight I guess
they think you might break the Wings off
or something airplanes don't fly too
good in helicopter mode okay so now
let's shift gears a little bit and talk
about how we know that our airplane is
within its center of gravity limits to
make this easier to explain let's go
back to our seesaw now we know our
fulcrum is our Center of lift and we
kind of have an idea of what the center
of gravity is but now we need a way to
figure out where the average weight is
on our seesaw to determine where our
center of gravity is and the first step
in doing that is to take a measurement
from a spot somewhere on the seesaw to
make things simple for this example
we'll take our measurements from the
left side of the seesaw now the name of
this spot where we start our
measurements is called our reference
datum and from here we simply measure
how far something is away from that spot
here in the good old us of a we take
measurements in inches but in Europe or
other countries you might take these
measurements in millimeters and if
you're lucky enough to be from Canada
you might take these measurements in
moose tracks I'm really not sure someone
must be getting mad right now because I
smell maple syrup now that you're mad at
me I guess now's probably not a good
time to ask you to buy my gear but I
promise it'll cheer you up and if you do
there's a link in the description if
that's something you want to check out
after you finish this lesson anyway
let's put a few weights on our seesaw
and talk about them let's say this one
right here is a 10 pound weight and it's
exactly 16 inches away from a reference
datum this distance that our weight is
from the datum is called the arm and if
you're using millimeters to make this
measurement your arm would be 406.4
millimeters and this is really important
to us because this helps us determine
how much torque this 10 pounds is
actually putting on our seesaw in
aviation we like to call this
measurement of torque the moment now I
would like to introduce you to a formula
that we use to calculate the moment Wham
this stands for weight times arm equals
moment so if you want to calculate how
much force or Torque this weight was
putting on our seesaw you simply
multiply our weight of 10 Pounds times
our arm of 16 inches to get the torque
or moment of 160 inch pounds now in this
example the moment we calculated is
given in relationship to the reference
datum but if we wanted we could also
determine our moment in relationship to
the fulcrum as well and to do that all
we need to do is find this distance here
between our fulcrum and our weight and
as you know 16 minus 9 is 7 so our arm
in this example is 7 inches now we can
pull out that wam formula to see that if
we were to multiply the weight of 10
Pounds times our arm of 7 inches the
weight is putting 70 inch pounds of
force on our fulcrum typically we don't
do calculations this way because we like
to make things easy on ourselves but I
think it's important to mention this so
you can fully understand the principle
but when it comes to calculating weight
and balance the main thing we care about
is finding where the average force is
being applied and this is what we call
our center of gravity to do this we need
to look at everything together on our
seesaw including the Seesaw itself
because a seesaw has weight as well and
if there were no weights on the Seesaw
and the fulcrum was off-centered the
Seesaw would no longer be balanced even
if it was by itself okay so let's take a
look at everything we have here first
we've got weight a which weighs 10
pounds with an arm of 3 inches because
it's three inches from the reference
datum 10 times 3 equals 30. so this
one's moment is 30 inch pounds from the
datum then we have weight B which also
weighs 10 pounds at 8 inches from the
datum so this guy's moment is 80 inch
pounds
then we have weight C which we've
already said weighs 10 pounds with an
arm of 16 inches so it's creating 160
inch pounds of force now the one
everyone forgets to do is the seesaw
let's say that the C cell weighs 10
pounds where is the seesaw's arm notice
that my weights are centered on these
arm locations so my arm is the center of
whatever the item is that I'm weighing
unless of course they tell you the
center of gravity is somewhere else and
if they did that would be the arm of the
Seesaw but in this case the center of
gravity on this seesaw is nine inches so
my arm is going to be nine inches here
and now that we know that we can find
Our Moment by multiplying ten times nine
so the seesaw's moment is 90 inch pounds
okay now that we know that we can look
at all this stuff together to find out
where our center of gravity is first
let's add up the total weight let's see
10 plus 10 plus 10 plus 10 equals 40. so
we have 40 pounds of total weight now we
need to find our total moment and by the
way the total arm is completely useless
nobody uses that anyway let's add 30
plus 80 plus 160 Plus 90 to get our
total moment of 360 inch pounds now to
figure out where our center of gravity
is all you need to do is remember this
simple formula mom's overweight and I'm
sorry I have to tell you that about your
mom but this is really going to help you
remember how to calculate your center of
gravity plus you're probably going to
need to be doing Weight and Balance
calculations anyways if she's going to
be flying with you
so now that we know that we'll take our
moment of 360 inch pounds and divide
that by our total weight of 40 pounds
and by George the center of gravity is
right there at our arm of 9 inches no
wonder this teeter-totter's balancing
itself out now here's where things start
getting a little weird this referenced
atom where we take our measurements from
can literally be anywhere on the Seesaw
it could be over here on the right side
of the board or we could put it right on
the fulcrum like this and we could count
to the negatives this direction and the
numbers on the right could be completely
normal but don't worry this is pretty
simple to figure out let's just take a
look at everything together just like we
did a minute ago
let's see we've got 10 pounds at an arm
of negative 4 this time to find Our
Moment We simply multiply 10 times
negative 4 to get negative 40. and if
you're that guy that slept through high
school math class I'll give you a quick
reminder a negative times a positive
equals a negative and a negative times a
negative equals a positive so this
moment is going to be a negative number
if the arm is a negative anyway we've
got another 10 pounds at negative 1 this
time so our moment on this one is
negative 10. then we have a 10 pound
weight over here at an arm of 70 inches
so it looks like our moment here is 70
inch pounds and don't forget our seesaw
which is 10 pounds and it looks like the
center is zero so this moment will
actually be zero in this example because
10 times 0 equals zero okay so let's
take a look at all these weights and
moments together like we did before once
again we have a total weight of 40
pounds but if we add minus 40 plus minus
10 plus 70 plus 0 we get a total of 20
inch pounds and remember how your mom's
overweight let's use that to figure out
where our center of gravity is and to do
that we'll take 20 inch pounds divided
by 40 so our center of gravity is at 0.5
inches from the datum wait a second it's
not a zero that means this thing is in
balance there we go that's better okay
now we've got a problem what do we need
to do to balance this thing out first we
need to figure out how far the center of
gravity needs to move in order to
balance this thing out
well it looks like it needs to move 0.5
inches to the left and if our CG was
negative 0.5 then it would need to move
0.5 inches to the right okay so now we
know how much we need to move our center
of gravity to get this thing balanced
out but we only have these three weights
to work with or the teeter-totter itself
but let's not make things hard on
ourselves by moving that around
here's a look at the formula you'll be
using anytime you need to shift weight
in order to get your center of gravity
to balance out I recommend taking a
snapshot of this or writing it down so
you have it for the written exam you may
also want to save this for when you get
your license in case you need to move
your mom around so you can balance out
the plan for that too anyway when you
look at this formula you can see that we
can solve any weight shift problems as
long as we have three of the four things
you see here here we have our weights to
be shifted we know we've got some 10
pound weights we can shift so let's see
what we need to do if we just move one
of those then we have our total weight
which we said was 40 pounds this CG
change is how much we need to move our
CG over we said that was negative 0.5 so
let's write that down here the only
thing we don't know is how much we need
to move that 10 pound weight so let's
make this x so now to figure out this
problem we need to solve this little
equation 10 divided by 40 equals
negative 0.5 divided by X if you
remember from your middle school algebra
days all we need to do here is cross
multiply so x times 10 equals 10x and 40
times negative 0.5 equals negative 20.
now we divide 10x by 10 and negative 20
by 10 as well
when we do that we can see that x equals
negative 2. that means we need to move
one of these 10 pound weights left
towards our negative side 2 inches now
if you're scratching your head right now
because you need a refresher on basic
algebra skills welcome to the 21st
century all you need to do is Google
search equation solver with steps or
algebra solver with steps and there are
literally websites out there that will
solve the problem for you and walk you
through the steps they took to solve it
I literally typed equation solver with
steps into Google here and this very
first one is a perfect example of what
I'm talking about I know right this
would have made my homework so much
easier when I was a kid anyway so now we
simply move over one of these 10 pound
weights two inches and now we see our
seesaw is once again balanced let's do
one more of these really quick so you
can see how they may ask you one of
these questions on the test let's say
they give us this picture here and they
tell us they want us to balance this
thing out
before we can do anything else we need
to figure out exactly where the center
of gravity is so we can figure out what
we need to do to make things easy on
ourselves let's write out everything we
see here just like we did in the other
examples first we had thing a here which
is 500 pounds and look at that those
jerks didn't tell us where the reference
to atom is well they did they just
didn't label it here if you notice all
these measurements were made from the
fulcrum so that's our datum in this
example and as you can see it's pretty
much identical to our last seesaw
example that means if this guy's to the
left of the datum his arm is going to be
negative 15 inches and if we multiply
500 times negative 15 we get a moment of
negative 7500 inch pounds then we have
thing B here which is 250 pounds and his
arm is 20 inches which makes his moment
5 000 inch pounds then last but not
least we have our super heavy 200 pound
Plank and when you first glance at this
it might seem a little confusing but
it's actually super simple look where
the Planck's center of gravity is it's
15 inches to the right of the fulcrum so
its arm is 15 inches that's how simple
this is now we can just multiply the
Plank's weight of 200 times 15 inches to
get a moment of 3 000 inch pounds all
right let's add up all these weights to
get a total weight of 950 pounds then
we'll add up all these moments to get a
total of 500 inch pounds and I don't
have to remind you that Mom's overweight
to find out where our center of gravity
is so 500 inch pounds divided by 950
pounds gives us the center of gravity of
0.52631579 inches wow this does seem
like an FAA question doesn't it they
could have easily put the CG right at
0.5 inches but they didn't and because
the CG is over here slightly to the
right of the fulcrum as you know the
Seesaw would fall over this way but
these magical FAA figures don't always
make a lot of sense so we have to back
up our common sense with our math skills
anyway we know our CG needs to move left
0.53 inches to get this thing to balance
out so now we need to decide what we
want to move to get this thing to
balance out now they're almost never
going to give you an option of moving
the plank over because that would be too
easy you'll likely need to move the big
weight over or this little one but since
our CG is so close to being balanced
let's just move this small one and to do
that let's pull out our waste shift
formula and see how much we need to move
it okay so the weight to be shifted is
going to be our 250 pound weight so
let's just put this in here
then we set our total weight is 950
pounds then we know we need to move our
CG over to the left 0.53 inches so that
will be negative 0.53 and this distance
that the 250 pound weight needs to move
is what we're trying to figure out so
let's call this x once again we'll cross
multiply these and that gives me 250X
equals negative 503.5
then we'll divide both sides by 250 and
that makes x negative 2.014 so if we
move the 250 pound weight left
2.014 or negative 2.014 inches that
means this thing is going to be balanced
out that wasn't too hard was it except
for finding .014 inches on this plank
okay so now let's take a look at one of
these on a real airplane and the first
thing you're going to notice is probably
some really wonky looking arms and
moments if you take a look at the arms
or what I like to call load stations on
this Cessna 172 Sierra you'll notice
that the datum here starts at the
firewall now for the past few minutes
we've been measuring everything off the
fulcrum and if you remember from earlier
we said that our Center of lift actually
changes with our angle of attack so this
isn't really the best place to put our
dat on most manufacturers pick something
that should never move so the firewall
is a very common place for them to put
the datum line then everything in front
of our datum will once again be negative
and every thing behind it will be
positive don't worry these problems are
going to be just as easy to solve as the
Seesaw problems and you might actually
find them a little bit easier because
the poh gives you a lot of tools to help
with the math okay so now you can look
down here and see that they built a
similar table to the one we've been
using with the seesaw first you can see
that they've given us a basic empty
weight of the airplane and they've even
calculated the moment for us wait a
minute how is 1642 pounds only creating
62.6 inch pounds of force that doesn't
make any sense at all this is something
you kind of have to watch out for notice
right here it says this is our moment in
inch pounds divided by a thousand so
this number is actually 62 600 inch
pounds okay that makes way more sense
notice on this chart here they don't
give us the arm if we want to know that
a lot of times they'll have something
like this that shows the arm location
for each spot in the airplane you could
actually put something as you can see
the center of gravity for the usable
fuel is 48 inches after the datum so if
we want to figure out that moment we
first need to know the weight of our
fuel we typically figure that aviation
fuel weighs about six pounds per gallon
so if there's 30 gallons in the tank
that would mean we have 180 pounds of
fuel and if we multiply that times our
load station of 48 inches is we'd get a
moment of eight thousand six hundred
forty inch pounds and will follow their
lead by turning this into an 8.6 okay so
now let's say you weigh 180 pounds and
you wanted to take your overweight mom
with you and she weighed 300 pounds 180
plus 300 equals 480. so we've got 480
pounds at load station 37. notice here
they actually give you a range because
the seats move back and forth so if
you're super tall and you need to sit
all the way back and your mom needs to
sit all the way back because her belly's
too big you might want to use load
Station 46 so 480 times 46 equals 22 080
inch pounds so let's throw 22.1 in here
okay so let's add one more thing in here
really quick maybe you wanted to bring
50 pounds worth of luggage with you on
this little adventure with your mom if
you were going to put it in this baggage
area back here you could just use this
load station and do the math the same
way we've been doing or you could use
this handy little tool that some pohs
have in them this little spaghetti chart
saves you the agony of having to use
your basic math skills and as you can
see it has most of the places you might
want to put something but for this
example we said that we're bringing 50
pounds of luggage and we're going to put
it in baggage area one so we'll find our
baggage area one line and move up the
line until we hit 50 pounds then we'll
move down the chart to see that our
moment for this bag is going to be five
or actually five times a thousand so
let's put a five in here now we can see
if we're going to be in limits so we
know for sure that we're going to be
able to control our airplane on this
little trip
so just like before let's add up all our
weights first
1642 plus 180 plus 480 plus 50. I'm
getting 2 352 pounds then we'll add up
all our moments we've got 62.6 plus 8.6
plus 22.1 plus 5. and I'm getting 98.3
on this one but remember technically
this is 98 300 inch pounds now let's
pull out this complicated looking
spaghetti chart and what we're looking
at here is a range where our center of
gravity can be and as long as it falls
within this chart we're going to be able
to control the aircraft okay so we
weighed 2 352 pounds so let's draw a
line straight over from here and notice
we also have a maximum weight limit of
2550 pounds we don't want to overload
our airplane but we're going to discuss
that more in the performance episode
then let's find our moment of 98.3 and
draw a line up from here
and as you can see we do fall inside of
our center of gravity envelope for the
normal category so we are going to be
able to take Mama out today but we're
quite a ways from the utility category
so spins might not be a good choice
today
let's do another one of these really
quick because a lot of pohs have a chart
that shows you where the airplane center
of gravity is instead of the moment
chart this poh has both and that's kind
of nice because you can choose whatever
is easiest for you and if you need to
shift the weight around this one's
probably going to be a little bit easier
to deal with let's say our plane weighs
the same and our center of gravity is 38
inches after the datum and once again
that would make our moment 62 600 inch
pounds once again we had 30 pounds of
fuel and that means we have 180 pounds
of fuel 48 inches after the datum and
that gives us a moment of 8640.
this time you're sitting up front by
yourself so we'll put 180 pounds 46
inches after the datum and that gives us
a moment of 8280
now Mom is sitting back here because her
belly's just too big she don't fit too
good up front she's been nervous about
something lately and she's been eating a
lot and because of that now she weighs
400 pounds and it looks like the rear
passenger seat is going to be 73 inches
after the datum so that gives us a
moment of 29 200 inch pounds and by the
way she still wants to bring her 50
pound bag with her so let's put that at
low station 95 again so that'll be
another 5 000 inch pounds okay so now
our total weight is 2452 pounds and if
we add up our total moment that gives us
a total moment of 113 720 inch pounds
now let's find our center of gravity by
acknowledging that Mom is overweight so
113 720 inch pounds divided by 2452
pounds equals 46.4 inches after the
datum
so are we going to be able to fly with
Mama
oddly enough we are I mean barely but
mama's gonna be fine back there now
right now you're probably noticing that
the Cessna 172s are really easy to keep
balanced and that's one of the reasons
why people love them so much but if you
were to fly like an old Bonanza d35 you
know the old v-tailed doctor Killers
those are really easy to get the center
of gravity too far aft and with that in
mind it's also not impossible to do it
on a 172 either I'll show you an example
here in just a minute and when we look
at that I'll show you how to shift the
weight a little bit if you did happen to
be out of limits but notice how close we
are to the line right now in these
situations it's really important that
you're using accurate data and I want to
talk about that for just a minute by now
you've probably heard of the acronym
Arrow which is an easy way to remember
the documents that you're required to
have onboard the aircraft anytime you go
fly the W in This Acronym stands for
weight and balance and while there's
nothing specific that says you need to
do the weight and balance every time you
go fly I want to point out something in
Far 91.9
except it's provided in paragraph D of
this section no person may operate a
civil aircraft without complying with
the operating limitations specified in
the approved airplane or rotorcraft
flight manual markings and placards or
as otherwise prescribed by the
certificating authority of the country
of registry now do you see the words
weight and balance in here me neither
but what we do see is that we must
comply with the operating limitations of
the aircraft well what does that mean
well the manufacturer of each aircraft
has determined that if there's too much
weight too far forward or there's too
much weight too far back in the plane
the airplane will not be balanced
properly and it will no longer be within
those operating limits that we just
mentioned and it's going to be difficult
to control
this is how the FAA words it in their
Weight and Balance advisory circular
120-27
accurately calculating the aircraft's
weight and CG before flight is essential
to comply with the certification limits
established for the aircraft these
limits include both weight and CG limits
by the way if you ever have questions
regarding weight and balance this
advisory circular is a great place to
look for the answer
anyway how do we know that we're
complying with the operating limitations
when we go fly
well just like you've kind of seen
inside of each Pilot's operating
handbook or airplane flight manual you
can find these limits and as long as you
stay Within These limits you'll be able
to control the airplane and fly safely
but the big question is how do we know
that we're accurately calculating an
aircraft's weight in CG before flight
one thing that a lot of people don't
realize is that anytime you add new
equipment or remove old equipment the
weight and balance information you see
in the poh is no longer reliable so
anytime we add or remove equipment the
airplane needs to be re-weighed and when
this happens the guy that re-weighs the
aircraft creates a new weight and
balance sheet so you can accurately
calculate your weight and balance for
that specific airplane
not only does this sheet need to go in
the maintenance records for the airplane
but a copy should also be added to the
poh aboard the aircraft so anyone who
flies it can make accurate calculations
here's a look at a real weight and
balance sheet from an aircraft I fly
regularly and when I make my weight and
balance calculations before I go fly
these are the numbers I use not the
generic numbers in the poh we'll still
be using the aircraft CG and moment
limits from the poh but the numbers we
use are going to come from the weight
and balance sheet so we know for a
hundred percent fact that we're safe
because I don't care how overweight my
mom is she's special to me my mom's not
actually overweight I'm just making a
point here let's do one more of these
with this real weight and balance sheet
and I'll show you how to shift the
weight if there's a problem
okay so if we look on this sheet we can
see that our basic empty weight is 1424
pounds and the center of gravity is
37.65 and Our Moment is 53 617 inch
pounds so let's put this over here in
this little chart from the poh to make
things easier on ourselves by the way
you don't actually want to write this in
your poh it's better to actually do this
on a scratch piece of paper unless of
course you want to see smoke coming out
your instructor's ears anyway if you're
trying to get this down to a Nats
whisker it's important to note that the
basic empty weight of the airplane that
we saw over on the weight and balance
sheet includes all the oil hydraulic
fluid or whatever other kind of fluids
it needs but it does not include usable
fuel so when we run the calculations
here we need to scratch this out now
let's say that you're going to sit up
front by yourself this time and you've
recently lost some weight so now you
only weigh 150 pounds and we'll just
multiply this times the arm wait a
second there's no arm on this chart and
a lot of older pohs don't show them you
either have to use a spaghetti chart
right here here like I showed you
earlier or you can run their example
numbers backwards to find the arm they
use to make their calculations and to do
that we still need to use the formula
moms overweight and this time it'll be
12 200 divided by 340 because remember
this moment is in thousands and this
gives us an arm or a CG a 35.88 let's
call it 35.9
now we can multiply that times our
weight to see that our moment is
5385. okay here's something kind of
weird as I just mentioned the basic
empty way does not include the fuel but
check out this weird note over on my
weight and balance sheet this plane was
weighed with 36 gallons of usable fuel
or full fuel tanks at first glance this
could throw you off and make you think
that the fuel is included in the basic
empty weight of the aircraft it sewn me
off before too but take a look down here
and see that the ANP that did this
subtracted all the usable fuel off of
these calculations it's really important
to note that it's not normal for an
airplane's basic empty weight to include
the fuel and the reason for this is
because the center of gravity can
actually shift on some airplanes as you
burn fuel the cge doesn't really change
a lot when a Cessna 172 Burns fuel so
it's not really a huge deal if your
weight and balance sheet on 172 was made
this way but I bring this up because I
want you to be sure that you're reading
these notes very carefully when you're
using these weight and balance sheets
okay let's get back to making our
calculations
so we said that our basic empty weight
does not include the fuel let's say we
have 25 gallons of usable fuel today
that means our fuel weighs 150 pounds
and for this one I'm going to be really
lazy the amp already looked up the arm
for me today and wrote it over here on
the weight and balance sheet it looks
like we have an arm of 48 inches and
that's around where most 172s are so
that passes the sniff test so I'm going
to use this arm and multiply that times
150 pounds to get a moment of 7 200 inch
pounds
let's see mama's been packing on the
pounds lately so now she weighs 450 and
so she's definitely gonna have to sit in
the back now once again I'll run my
calculations backwards to see that she's
sitting at low station 70 and that makes
her moment 31 500 inch pounds and on
this trip she's wanting to bring a 120
pound bag so you throw it in the back
here in the baggage compartment and I'll
use this spaghetti chart this time to
calculate this one and it looks like we
have a moment of 11 400 inch pounds okay
so this gives us a total weight of 2294
pounds and a total moment of 109 100
inch pounds and if we look at this chart
you can see that we're below our Max
gross weight but this time our center of
gravity is a little after what it needs
to be based on this chart it looks like
we need to reduce Our Moment by a
thousand inch pounds but to be safe
let's say we need to reduce it by 3 000
inch pounds but here's the problem some
of these older pohs don't have a CG
envelope that depicts the arm this chart
only gives us a moment envelope so we
can either do one of two things the
first is to use this spaghetti chart
I know we need to reduce the moment by
3000 inch pounds so let's try something
what if I took this 120 pound bag and
put it on Mama's lap well let's see
first we'll find 120 on this chart then
move over to our line and just like we
mentioned before this weight is
producing 11 400 inch pounds of force
let's move up the rear passenger chart
and see what the difference is
if I move up the chart to 120 pounds I'm
getting about 8 200 inch pounds so 11
400 minus eight thousand two hundred
equals three thousand two hundred and we
said we wanted to reduce the moment by
three thousand inch pounds so this is
going to work
the other method is a little bit more
precise this document is called the type
certificate data sheet or tcds and you
should be able to find this in your
aircraft's maintenance records or the
faa's website and basically what this is
is the faa's official list on all the
limitations on this aircraft this is
especially handy on older aircraft where
the pohs are kind of crappy and they
don't give good clear information
to use this document we just need to
find our exact aircraft along with the
correct specifications and below that we
can find a list of the airplane's
limitations and if you notice for the
normal category we've got two different
sets of limits and our total weight
today is 2294 pounds so we should be
using this one up here it looks like our
Ford CG limit is 38.5 inches and our app
CG limit is 47.3 inches so if we use our
CG formula of moms overweight we can see
that our actual center of gravity is
47.55 inches so now we can see that our
actual center of gravity is exactly 0.25
inches after where it needs to be and
now that we know that we can fix it by
pulling out that weight shift formula we
used earlier on the seesaw
okay so this time we know that we need
to move 0.25 inches forward let's call
it a half inch to be safe and give
ourselves a little bit of a buffer so
let's put that here in the change in CG
spot now how far are we moving it well
let's try moving it from the baggage
compartment up to the back seat with
Mama again
so removing it from load station 95 to
low station 70. that's a difference of
25 inches so let's write that in here
our total weight is 2294 so we'll put
that in this spot and we're trying to
figure out how much weight we need to
move so let's call this X and I can see
that you're getting kind of tired so
I'll solve this one for you and it looks
like we need to move at least 45.88
pounds up to the back seat with Mama or
once again just make her hold that thing
she's probably going to want her 120
pounds of candy bars anyways for the
flight I'm sure she's going to get
hungry at some point and you don't want
that much weight shifting on you during
flight if she reaches back to get them
hey I really appreciate you guys letting
me make fun of your mamas today I hope
you learned something I would really
appreciate you hitting the like button
for me it really helps me out and when I
get the next Private Pilot lesson up
I'll put that right here if you want to
learn how to use foreplay to do weight
and balance my friend put together a
great video on that and I'll put that
one right here if you'd like to focus on
weight and balance a little bit longer
before you move on with your training
and as always sit yeah coach you're not
gonna believe this I just bought a free
pilot training I'm going to keep on
watching